best case scenario for me personally is
somehow my college gets paid for best
case scenario for me is that I don't get
destroyed for my stances on and like
politically because I did align with
Trump and I did vote for him and so
hopefully the people who do find that
out don't stop being my friends or
something like that
it's gonna give me better opportunities
when I graduate high school for me to
enter colleges can be better for me
paying my tuition paying my grants and
also getting scholarships and that's
also gonna spend to the part of the
economy which is gonna help boost
hopefully and it's gonna give me a
better chance an opportunity to get the
job I want things don't change much that
he's just he's a lame-duck president
that can't get anything done and in four
years we elect somebody better he
changed the gun laws and he'd be more
lenient on convicted felonies
what I hope to happen for my family is
that family from overseas will be able
to come into this country under our
hopefully good immigration rules laws
since I'm gonna open my own automotive
shop I would hope that he keeps the
automotive industry stable just like I
Obama saved automotive industry you know
finally get a hint at what it really was
to be president not a fluke not wanting
it but he'll really get to understand
the pressures behind the present
see and I'll stroke out worst case for
me personally as I get kicked out of the
country that we become isolated as
Muslim Americans we become distant from
the rest of this nation and our position
to where we are no longer welcomed in
this country making an already
vulnerable population extremely more
vulnerable I'm not really in a state
where either is going to bother me I'm a
white female I don't really have a lot
of prejudice against me so I don't
really see this kind of playing out
badly for me which is really fat that I
actually get to clean that worst case
scenario is if Donald Trump builds the
wall that stays the way it is because
it's pretty bad right now it's been
pretty bad bail last eight years I don't
personally know if there's any upside
for me under a trump administration I'm
a small business owner and based on the
way I do things
his philosophy isn't gonna work for me
[Music]